une séance dans un contexte économique
et sanitaire particulier face à cette
situation les conseillers départementaux
ont voté plusieurs mesures pour soutenir
différents pans de l'économie yvelinoise
d'abord l'agriculture des aides
attribuées jusqu'à 23 mille euros aux
exploitations ayant subi une perte du
chiffre d'affaires de 30%
autre secteur accompagné l'automobile
les yvelines ont voté un partenariat
avec le groupe psa pour se porter
acquéreur de terrains appartenant au
constructeur un investissement de 8
millions d'euros pour la collectivité
qui permettra la production de l'opel
moka à terme sans les investissements
faits par psa possible grâce à l'apport
substantiel du département l'apport
financier substantiel du département
cette voiture n'aurait probablement pas
été montée à poissy et donc probablement
les trois mille cinq cents ouvriers se
serait retrouvé en situation fort
délicate
cette séance l'occasion aussi de
récompenser les pompiers des yvelines
mobiliser face à la colite 19
chaque conte pierre recevra une prime
entre 250 et 1000 euros en fonction de
leur présence autre mesure votée la
création de l'organisme foncier
solidaire c'est vraiment une façon de
favoriser l'accession à la propriété des
jeunes ménages de la classe moyenne
le département est aussi au chevet des
commerces de centre ville
une enveloppe de 2 7 millions d'euros a
été votée pour soutenir plus de 600
commerçants et artisans dans 47 commune
yvelinoise